well the family of a Colorado mother who
vanished nearly three weeks ago is
asking the public to help bring her home
Kelsey Bharath was last seen
Thanksgiving Day at a supermarket with
her one-year-old daughter she was
reported missing 10 days later Nikki
batise is here with new details on the
investigation including the strange
clues from Barrett's cell phone Nikki
good morning good morning when
investigators searched Kelsey's home
they found her car's her clothes her
toothbrush even cinnamon rolls
apparently untouched since Thanksgiving
yesterday Bharath smother choked back
tears as she appealed for her daughter's
safe return Kelsey we just want you home
cause if you can't we won't quit looking
it's been 20 days and cheryl Bharath
heard from her daughter Kelsey the 29
year old was last seen at this Safeway
on November 22nd where surveillance
cameras captured her shopping with her
daughter Caylee shortly before Patrick
freezy Barrett's fiance and Kylie's
father picked up the one-year-old
someone knows where she's at she's not
the kind that runs off this is
completely out of character on November
25th three days after the Woodland Park
Colorado resident vanished police say
her cell phone pinged near Gooding Idaho
nearly 600 miles away that same day two
text messages were apparently sent from
the device one told her employer Doss
aviation where she was a flight
instructor she would not be showing up
to work the following week the second
message was sent to Frazee Woodland Park
police chief miles de young said it was
bear's mother who reported her missing
December second more than a week after
those texts were sent
that's a question we'll have to ask
Patrick de Young says he is unaware of
any reports of domestic violence
involving the couple Frazee's home has
not been searched and police describe
him as cooperative he declined to appear
at the press conference Monday we are
treating Kelsey's disappearance as a
missing persons case at this time we
have not identified anyone as a suspect
and are asking the public for any
information that might help us find her
Bharath family has created a Facebook
page called missing mother Kelsey
Bharath police say all the planes at the
flight school where she worked are
accounted for Frazee who has been caring
for Caylee has not responded to our
request for comment it's a very bizarre
troubling story we can only hope she's
alive yes yes yes you know definitely
hope that Nikki thank you very much